let's talk about the gaming industry
hundreds of millions of people around
the world will be unboxing video games
and downloading new updates this week
adding billions of dollars to an
industry that's already richer than both
the global box office and the music
business combined for the huge success
of video games has come at a cost to
many people who make them so what's
happening to the workers behind the
screen
[Music]
it's pretty incredible really just how
massive this industry is and how much
it's evolved over the decades
[Music]
this was nimah trough the very first
game machine that debuted in new york in
1940 fast forward to the arcade games of
the 70s pone gaming consoles computer
games in the 80s and 90s online gaming
at the turn of the century and now
mobile gaming and eSports teams we're
full time professional gamers fill
stadiums and earn millions yes millions
of dollars games are definitely on the
rise and I think there's a lot of
potential for games to do good you're
seeing in programs open up for gaming
getting a full scholarship ride so I
think it is becoming more mainstream
let's wrap our heads around some numbers
in 2016 a third of the world's
population were video gaming that's two
and a half billion people in 2017 more
than 660 million people watched other
people play video games on platforms
like twitch and YouTube in 2018 the
gaming industry made at least a hundred
and thirty billion dollars and this is a
business that's still growing by about
ten percent a year that's a pretty
exciting industry for aspiring animators
developers and coders to want to be a
part of and staff salaries for
developers are a lot higher than your
average job in the u.s. a developer can
earn around 100,000 US dollars a year in
India it's about 500,000 rupees or six
thousand US dollars a year a lot higher
than the average person's $2,000 yearly
salary you know I'm so glad I got in the
game design it's cool to be able to
create the kind of games that we play
and 2019 was the year we found out just
how big a price people pay to be part of
the world's biggest entertainment
industry the biggest problem that the
games industry faces right now and
something that we're battling head-on
are the really inhumane working hours
that the video game industry workers are
having to endure this is called crunch
crunch culture is still a huge issue in
the industry
it's when workers are put under enormous
pressure to work overtime in order to
meet game launch deadlines before the
studio Treyarch released call of duty
black ops 4 last year some testers said
that crunch time involved working 70
hours of weeks for weeks on end the
gaming website Kotaku says some of those
guys earned only $13 an hour while black
ops made about 500 million dollars in
just a few days this multiplayer mode is
super fun dude some testers working on
fortnight another massive and free
online game also reported 70 hour
working weeks and what happens a lot is
that after launch many workers are laid
off once again get shipped and players
can buy it and play it then it's a sort
of a big layoff every two to four years
and that fee increases the more
marginalised you are a woman on a binary
person opposite color Kevin just
mentioned women and they have major
concerns about the gaming work culture
as many as a billion gamers are thought
to be women and only 19% of the industry
staff are female and ever since the
hashtag v2 movement more and more women
are coming forward with allegations of
rape and harassment
sadly sexual harassment is also a
genuine issue for women in the games
industry along the time as you may
imagine women are still only a minority
of video games industry workers and they
don't have a voice about of the time or
even if they try and complain they're
their big shout out we spoke to one
designer who even made a game about what
it was like to be a woman in the
industry right each man says a line that
someone has actually said to me it was
kind of like going through my past years
of being in the industry and I'm picking
out like the worst things men have said
just putting them all in one room in
2014 a scandal known as gamergate
consumed the gaming world
it was a huge online culture war about a
lot of things
but at the heart of it was the treatment
of women in a male-dominated industry at
the time a developer named Zoe Quinn and
others received rape and death threats
so much so that even the FBI was called
in to investigate people like feminist
media critic and Meeta sarkeesian came
under pretty heavy fire for posting this
damsel in distress trope as a recurring
trend does help to normalize extremely
toxic patronizing and paternalistic
attitudes about women workers have been
trying to unionize to demand things like
better pay and fair treatment by gaming
studios but it's not been easy Marshman
Athena game developers conference in San
Francisco some industry heads bosses
decided to create the panel discussion
about how you know we don't need
unionization in the games industry that
conference triggered an online movement
called game workers unite and it's now
an international organization whose
mission even has the backing of u.s.
presidential hopeful Bernie Sanders
every month we have a different place in
the world that says yes to hell with
this we need to begin talking the bosses
think that they can get away with it
they create this idea that you know you
are lucky to be working in the games
industry and you know if you if you're
gonna complain you know we can find a
hundred people that will do your job so
this creates this cultural fear so is
the industry doing anything right while
some companies are taking important
steps gaming studios including Treyarch
which we spoke about earlier say they're
trying to reduce the crunch culture the
game workers unite movement has formally
been accepted into the independent
Workers Union of Great Britain and some
companies like Blizzard Entertainment
and EA also made glass doors 100 best US
companies to work for in 2018
although EA did fall off that list in
2019 games industry was kind of a woken
politically past few years have
definitely given me a lot of hope for
women in the industry for consumers and
developers there's a lot to look forward
to and the hope is that as this industry
grows and rakes and
billions more gaming workers will reap
the benefits of a business that at the
heart of it is meant to be about fun
thanks for watching and for sending us
your ideas on stories you'd like us to
cover next
our team is already working on new
episodes for the new year so keep
sending us your questions comments and
thoughts on Twitter Facebook and YouTube
you